[Musique]
et on commence avec le chiffre du jour
Gabriel 150 pourquoi et bien 150
Mathilde c'est le nombre de personnes
qui vont être embauchées en CDI par le
constructeur automobile Renault du site
historique de Flin un recrutement qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
reconversion progressive consacrée à
l'économie circulaire le
reconditionnement de véhicules
d'occasion et de pièces détachées de
toute marque c'est le projet refactory
alors un peu de patience he car ces
embauches se dérouleront entre 2024 et
2026 en mars 2024 d'ailleurs sortira la
toute dernière voiture zoeé et c'est la
dernière ligne droite du concours
créatrice d'avenir le jury des Yvelines
a rendu son verdict oui et cinq
yvelinoises parviennent à la sélection
régionale du concours elles peuvent
maintenant prétendre accéder à la grande
finale ces créatrices d'entreprises
représenteront le département dans les
six catégories de prix impact innovation
artisanat mixité des ingénieurs
quartiers et prix du public on le
rappelle il s'agit du premier concours
francilien destiné à l'entrepreneuriat
des femmes les Lauréades pourront
bénéficier d'une visibilité et se
partager 60000 €. prochaine étape donc
le 7 novembre pour désigner les 15
finalistes régionales on va parler sport
à présent et plus particulièrement de
basket parce que ça y est c'est le grand
soir pour Victor wenbanama oui cette
nuit le natif du chaîner rancour fera
son bapthême du feu en NBA face au
Dallas maverque en début un début sans
trop de stress puisqu'il confiait lors
d'une conférence de presse cette nuit
j'ai un peu des papillons dans le ventre
chez moi c'est un peu le cas avant
chaque match même si ça dépend bien sûr
des enjeux de l'importance du match je
ne me mets pas à trembler et à
transpirer non plus mais j'ai un peu mal
au ventre on souhaite donc bonne chance
à Liv Linois coup d'envoi cette nuit à
3h30 heure française et on poursuit avec
du football vous avez une bonne nouvelle
pour les supporters du FC Versailles les
supporters attendaient ça avec
impatience les Versaillais se seront de
retour à montboron pour le prochain
match de Coupe de France ils
affronteront le FC Fleury 91 le samedi
28 octobre à 14h30 depuis la saison
dernière aucun match nationau ne pouvait
se jouer sur le terrain sans dérogation
le stade versaillais est toujours en
travaux pour homologuer son éclairage
leur rencontre contre les Lyons se
jouera à Versailles pour un match de
Coupe de France dans l'après-midi donc
aucun éclairage n'est nécessaire et
enfin direction Guill en cour la ville
nous propose de redécouvrir les jeux
vidéos de notre jeunesse oui Sonic ou
encore Pacman tous vous accompagneront
dans un univers rétro et amusant pendant
une après-midi vous serez plongé dans un
univers vintage cet événement hors du
temps vous offrira également un moment
familial qui pourra bien être rempli de
nostalgie on l'imagine rendez-vous donc
ce vendredi 27 octobre dès 14h30 au
centre social du pont du rottoir et bien
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le has#tag 7et news